[Music]
thank you you guys excited to see me huh
that's nice I'm happy to be here in Los
Angeles a little jet-lagged oh I call
one of those noon red-eye flights I call
all flights the red-eye makes me feel
like a real business man people love
told me they took the red-eye oh man the
red eyes great get on the plane at 1:00
a.m.
sit upright for six hours land in New
York at that sweet sweet time for fifty
five in the morning at work by 8:00
passed out in the conference room by
8:15 looking for a new job at 8:30
Loretta went to Chicago yeah they're
really nice Walgreens in Chicago it's
true they convert an old bank into a
Walgreens it's beautiful they use the
vault is the vitamin section I walked in
there I was so impressed I went on
Twitter and I wrote I have to give out
my first annual best Walgreens award the
winner is Chicago Milwaukee Avenue
location some guy writes back
immediately the cops killed a guy there
a year ago okay what do you want me to
do now take the award away I can't do
that it's the first annual Todd berry
best Walgreens award this is huge I'm
not gonna take it back as a guy was shot
there a year ago it's not like it
happened while I was in the store it's
not like I was walking around the candy
aisle a guy gets gunned down next to me
I'm like this is a nice wall great
I wonder if he noticed that's the
original tile good food in Chicago I'm
kind of a picky eater though yeah I have
three categories of food foods I like
foods I don't like but I understand why
people like them then their foods that
baffle me food I like let's pick an easy
one pizza yum delicious no need for
further discussion second category sushi
don't like it totally get why people
like it though what a beautiful
beautiful awful tasting food that is I
remember the one time I tried it 17
years ago at the Cincinnati Airport I
did not enjoy it no second chances for
sushi
your blue Atsushi give you every
opportunity to be good with a quarter of
a bite that I took spit out immediately
third category foods that baffle me egg
salad
if I'm in a diner and I see some more
direct salad all I can think is so you
read all 75 pages of that menu and
that's the item that popped oh honey I
found it top of page 59 flip a head cold
smelly eggs
I'm sorry cold smelly disgusting eggs
that's so excited I read that wrong
smash together with cold awful
mayonnaise also made with cold smelly
eggs served on my bread maybe this is
why we go to restaurants thanks a lot
everyone
[Applause]